well this is awkward nobody ever asked
for what we're about to do but we think
you'll love it anyway you remember the
cartoon the toys the old movies the new
movies the video games the popsicles and
the disgusting cream pies but you
probably repressed your memories of the
rock musical I got a story to tell when
we were coming by shell Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles coming out of their shells
the Ninja Turtles have literally come
out of their shells and into bedazzled
denim vests to replace the ninja
fighting you love with bad lip-syncing
awkward dancing even the first batch
made the music scene and pretending to
play their non-functional instruments
in a VHS special that proves that people
would buy anything in the 90s if you
slap the turtle on it
prepare to be blown away by music
someone thought was good enough to play
in public I mean they do rap they do
rock and roll they do you know an easy
listening like this Lane Beach Boys
knockoff California days but tubas got
no ultraviolet rays Oh too bad
this rat that mixed vanilla eyes look
like to park telephone info favorite
word I use it all the time
how are you hard the one where they just
yell at you to be straight an April
O'Neill power ballad
and splinters weird slow bruce
springsteen homage skipping stone
I must move
he can make a funny but he cannot make a
singie but it's not just for sweaty guys
in crappy costumes wobbling around
making awkward banter with each other
there's also sort of applied thrill as a
homeless man shredder steals all the
world's music somehow from here I'll be
able to suck the music from the earth
and take control which is controlled by
this meter thing whatever that can also
be defeated by cloaking tissues and the
power of song look none of it makes
sense at least you get a good 5 minutes
of shredder roasting an audience of
children I think I've seen your face on
a milk carton recently that your sister
cousin
semadar can get a date that's your mom
how would you like a one-way ticket to
my Technodrome Oh bird you're that
little boy sure is gonna pork your mom
bro so strap in for a concert field only
the black nerd could love ya abortion
Oh full updated references where to this
product placement on the back of our
American Express card don't leave oh my
valid and grown men pretending that a
cartoon is real Bob was telling me all
about this incredible group that's
playing on the ground in the sewers of
New York I think this group and this
albums gonna be around for a long time
and I wouldn't be surprised if they want
two Grammy Award the turtles were trying
to develop a story within their show in
what has to be the worst thing ever made
with the Ninja Turtles in it not so fast
on his trailer guy who are you
hello I'm gonna stash Creek I wade
through the crap of yesteryear so you
don't have to I just waited through a
lot of crap by Fred oh the Ninja Turtles
suck pile goes even deeper than you know
how about we wish you a turtle Christmas
huh her musical Christmas special of
course check it out hallo Dee oh geez
why does Leonardo have a Jamaican accent
nobody knows how about Turtle Tunes the
one worthy reword public domain songs
with lyrics about stranger danger
what the how many musicals did they make
just a few markets oh you say you love
out of our shells no well then you'll
love their even lower budget follow up
getting down in your town
oh stop please okay but enough now watch
their appearance on Oprah guys let me
ask you this do you sometimes wish that
April was a turtle all right I'll try to
talk her into it interspecies
relationships for months that kid can
terrified I don't need this Regis and
Kathie Lee Bobby
bulletproof vest so what is it hey dude
stay off my cell why Barbara Walters
Oh can't take it anymore now feast your
eyes on this promotional video for the
LA subway system good luck is trying to
sidetrack the RTD Metro blue line don't
worry April you can count on us what is
even happening I hate the past
damn you nostalgia critic story
absolutely nothing of value Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles your childhood
always sucked you just didn't know it
now y'all know discover and how we got
to be who we are man
the past is really weird be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers hey
screen junkies looking for a nostalgia
chaser then check out for all new
episodes of our exclusive series with
how it should have ended after credits
we brought new after credit scenes out
of the shadows for you to enjoy
including Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
which you can watch totally free right
now click the box to check it out now
cowabunga buckle up buckaroo sweet
dreams are made of this the goggles they
do nothing say no to Hydra cab I am a
handsome man baby squids like muffins